dan when it comes to selecting films how
important is the celebrity factor do you
and Theo think that films that have
recognizable stars have an edge over
films that have sort of no name talent
so to speak and you also factor in the
potential presence of these quote stars
at the festival as part of the appeal
dad part yeah I mean you anyone saying
differently we probably kind of lying I
mean you have to take an effect that in
consideration this is Hollywood we are
in Hollywood other festivals maybe other
cities that people can attend or that
may not be the same kind of factor we're
is we're in the backyard of all this you
know our festival takes place right next
door to where the Oscars are taking
place in a few hours like this like you
know where we are so that's part of it I
mean we have open night which is always
been kind of a stark of premier platform
we won't premiere films you want the
highest quality films we also want a
certain star Packer that's part of what
hoping that is my carpet big event one
emergency ailis Hollywood with the indie
filmmakers to kind of bring that
together that's kind of been the way
we've done that that's what flaws before
that night so in that standpoint we're
looking for that but the program as a
whole I mean not as much I mean it's
more about the film's how they fit
programs the type of films they are and
and just and again a competition setting
just you know which ones are up for
certain awards in which films will win
in which valuable program and the
festival not so concerned with a regular
program with the celebrity factor as
much as that factors in open night most
like I stopped trying to get it but yeah
I mean you know if someone's gonna be
attending it's good to know we never we
don't really know that before I people
would say that all time and you don't
really know I mean they could say
they'll tend to like the attendants nice
to know at all but if we don't like the
film it says so doesn't work and it's
not something that we feel it's gonna
fit opening night and not going to fit
the program then we'll have to vote to
put aside and strongest they're not
playing the film I mean it's just it's
not like okay they'll come but if they
don't come this is dennie by not come I
mean it son doesn't guarantee anything
and this talent comes to celebrities but
it's good to know at least that people
are aware and there they are supporting
the project doesn't have never it hurts
that you know a celebrity is
you know backing a film and if you like
the film is great i go we want to
program this and that person behind it
i'll talk about it look at it out there
that'll help with potential attendants
and things and people getting the word
out you know we want people to get
excited with the festival get the word
out for the festival for their for their
film for our festival and for the other
filmmakers and everyone wants a good
crap and to mingle with stars or whatnot
but you know you also want to just go
back to again the simple thing of is the
film good or not you know is it we've
had a lot of films over the years just
with celebrities and awful awful and may
be easily rejecting them on me there's
just no you know and you don't they know
we know they're going to come and hide
or I mean we don't even get to that
point it with some of those films i mean
it's it's like you know grant or nah i'm
not talking my phones like a list stars
i mean that that's that's we have had
that we're gonna cover their bachelier
let's start on stuff that's of quality
but like the stuff that or be stars and
people that are like no recognizable
faces and TV or not good talented actors
that my feeling is are just they're just
doing stuff for hobby and they pick up a
camera cuz they can and just make
something and and like anyone else it's
not easy and it's not like you can just
pick up a camera make a film make it
good just because you are such as such
that doesn't work so we've seen some
films over the years i won't name any
names with some movies urges you had
some talia my god i was that was so wish
that would work the wish that was good
because we could programmable we just
can't I mean there's some films you'd be
surprised some of the stuff it was again
I go back to I feel like my personal
philosophy on those films is actors with
downtime unpickable camera to make a
movie get some friends together because
we have actor friends that are working
and you know recognizable faces and
we'll make a film and submits always
festival everyone would just love us but
there's been some films like that that
are just pretty bad really really bad it
comes again they're lacking a lot of
editing is bad it sound pause but you
know it's like anything else it's got to
be a certain production values from
quality and sort of filmmaking qualia
they don't then they lack because again
you know filmmaking difficult and you
have to know what you're doing and just
because they're touted accurate about
cameras I mean that that's going to
happen better if they trusted someone
else directive home for them but again
it's
part of the directors want to be actors
act when we directors and that kind of
thing so you've seen some films that no
it'sit's you know you want to program a
quality film on the screen so there is a
you know it gives them a more exposure
look like you need a chance to think
about it so I'll say that like you see a
celebrity oh I like this guy's great in
this so you're gonna give an extra
little maybe give a second look again
just like I don't want to give it you
money you know I'll be honest but if the
film is a goodness not is just not it's
not the part in this apt apart it's just
not only wouldn't be fair but also you
know we're trying to program you know
what we programs we're picking so we say
oh you who pigs movie oh I did oh you
picked a that's what you're gonna that's
what you're putting on the screen like
that's you know I don't want I don't
want to be that sets kind of
embarrassing so you want you know that
would reflect on us if he pickles really
just based on what such as is in it but
yeah but then movie was awful oh yeah
well what you say so yeah it does go
back to the quality of the film but yes
I think it does help I can't hurt in
general it can't hurt to have and
telling your film and just can't outside
of a certain fest that are strictly
indie you know some fests are very like
staunch about it wants strictly
independent film they want any you know
there's some of those out there but
outside of that yeah I think it does it
does help to have any time you felt
certainly and if they're back in the
film certainly certainly that question
you